so as we've seen donald trump's second
impeachment trial get into day two and
then now into day three there have been
a lot of questions about
just what has donald trump actually been
doing these last few days and even the
couple of weeks since he left office and
there's a very interesting
new article in the washington post from
josh dossey and ashley parker that tells
the story of donald trump at mar-a-lago
in palm beach florida
doing a lot of golfing not surprisingly
doing a lot of just
calling old friends and trying to
reconnect with people he reportedly
continues to have
many political aids on his payroll just
around him
sycophants of sorts of different kinds
but this washington post article really
tells the story of a
former president and former sort of big
shot businessman at least uh
at least to some degree whose world is
really crumbling around him increasingly
isolated from most of
the of of popular culture half the
country or more
disgusted with him unwilling to
patronize his businesses
anymore and while as josh dossey
writes in the washington post trump is
confident that he is going to be
acquitted uh he is increasingly
disturbed
partially by the absolutely bizarre
performance of his attorney bruce castor
on monday
the free association rorschach test sort
of thing that took place which we
covered yesterday
trump disappointed in bruce castor's
performance uh donald trump also uh
reportedly
um not pleased in general with how
republicans have been
uh some republicans have been responding
to the evidence presented
so far and uh donald trump is in this
sort of
bubble and we know that donald trump was
in a bubble while he was president of
the united states
but he seems to sort of further be
protecting himself with this bubble
uh and part of it interestingly enough
is coming from the fact that donald
trump is
banned from a lot of social media
platforms were donald trump not banned
from twitter right now
he would be not only tweeting but also
spending more time on twitter and maybe
seeing that there are even many
republicans disgusted with donald
trump's role
in inciting the riots on january 6th the
fact that donald trump
uh has been removed from twitter and a
number of other platforms
has placed him in what many people
around him
are saying it is a state of being adrift
no idea of what to do day to day no idea
of what comes next
and whether there is a future for donald
trump's political life and business life
and i think this is another aspect that
it just sort of remains to be seen like
does donald trump go back to
doing real estate deals at this point
the one thing
that has been mentioned by a number of
sources that uh dossie and parker cite
in their washington post piece is that
donald trump
is calmer than was expected he was
reportedly screaming
about bruce castor's terrible
performance
but trump seems relatively calm as he is
adrift and unclear about what the future
is of his business
and political life but donald trump
reportedly
furious with some republicans including
congresswoman liz cheney who did vote to
impeach donald trump in the house of
representatives
house republican leader kevin mccarthy
who said trump does have some
responsibility for the attack on the
capital then ended up backtracking when
those comments exploded so the the
general sense here
is that this is a trump uh surrounded by
the most extreme sycophants because who
else would be left at this point
to even be around donald trump given
what's taken place
off social media partially because he's
been kicked off
furious with the republicans that he
believes have abandoned him
and unclear as to what the future of his
life
uh even is at this point in time now one
other interesting detail about donald
trump during
the impeachment trial and in the days
leading up
early on you'll remember that a bunch of
donald trump's uh
lawyers for the second impeachment trial
quit it was i guess
a week ago sunday not this past sunday
but the previous one
part of what we believe led to that is
that donald trump
was insisting to his first legal team
that they defend trump in the
impeachment trial by arguing that
trump's claims about a stolen election
were
were true this is sort of like a an
affirmative defense
um if you're accused of uh killing
someone and you're being charged with
murder
one defense would be i didn't do it i
just i didn't kill anybody
an affirmative defense would be i did
kill them but it's not murder because it
was self-defense
and what donald trump wanted was the
affirmative defense of okay yeah
i did tell people to go to the capitol
and they were being inspired by me
but it was because i rightly identified
that the election was stolen
from me trump's initial uh defense team
reportedly thought that that was an
absolutely terrible idea
uh knowing donald trump's instinct for
self-sabotage and inflicting
you know unforced unforced problems upon
himself
uh they didn't go with that and donald
trump ultimately
getting new lawyers but that is not the
case that is being made and the case
that we
we have already seen previewed by donald
trump's attorneys bruce castor and david
shone
and which we are going to continue to
see today and as the the defense mounts
um are simply that donald trump didn't
incite the riot
period and uh that another source of
isolation
and fury and confusion from donald trump
so i don't know what the future of
donald trump's life is
what i hope happens is that the country
can move on from trump but at the same
time and we're going to talk about this
on the friday show
i do actually hope for the sake of the
left that donald trump tries to start a
third party
because so many republicans have said in
in surveys
that they'd be willing to abandon the
republican party and follow trump
trump starting a third party could be
exactly what the left needs
to really make some progress over the
next two four six
even eight years so we'll be talking
more about that on tomorrow's program
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and thankfully
there's a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video